[Music]
before we get to our more about less
segment vanessa we wanted to talk we
were talking off mike here about
awkwardness
and you talk about being a recovering
awkward person yes so awkwardness i
think
it dresses up as different things
so i think some people they feel awkward
and they shut down they inhibit they go
quiet they go into their introvertedness
they try to hide
other people their awkwardness dresses
up as being big over-the-top dramatic
interrupters show offers
and so i think that awkwardness is this
very unique trait because it shows up
differently in different people but you
don't always know that you're seeing it
right like you might meet someone and be
like god they're a show-off well that's
just because they're scared
like i think awkwardness comes because
we're for me at least i am awkward
because i'm scared of being judged i'm
scared you're not gonna like me and i'm
scared i'm unworthy that i'm should be
with you that i'm not worthy of your
time or your conversation but you
wouldn't know that because it dresses up
as me shutting down me closing in me
being scared me being quiet and so i
think that awkwardness is this thing
that if we can talk about it we can see
how it's dressing up for people and get
to the real heart of what people are
afraid of yeah yeah and so you're afraid
not of the awkwardness itself but of the
way that people perceive you now ryan we
were downstairs in the bathroom you were
you were saying something that i found
really fascinating yeah i uh i i don't
care what people think about me like
as long as they're interpreting me
correctly
that that's what matters so
you know it's like if we were talking
you're like oh man that ryan nicodemus
guy he really you know you tweet
something about how i hate puppies or
something and i would be like what did i
do like that's where that's my pet
people like wait what did i do to make
you think like you're interpreting me
wrong
but if you went and tweeted like oh ryan
nick dimi he's a minimalist and you know
he's stupid i'll be like yeah i'm pretty
stupid and i'm a minimalist you know
like i don't care what people think but
i do care about how they interpret me
and it's it's interesting because like
this this little conversation is so
valuable for so many people uh
especially for me because like with
certain people
they will come across as defensive or
irritated or having the resting bothered
face yeah and instead of me reacting to
what uh i think their cues mean yeah i
tell myself like oh they don't know how
to handle the situation right now
they're nervous they're awkward they're
awkward and it helps me so much um to
de-escalate things yeah i also think
it's important it's beautiful what you
said that your
your fear comes from oh they're not
gonna understand who i truly am
this is really hard for the opposite so
i think i have the opposite as you which
is i have horrible imposter syndrome so
i think i truly am unworthy
so for me it's not that i want people to
see that i'm truly unworthy i'm trying
to convince him that i am worthy even
though i sometimes feel very unworthy
so there's i think different ways it can
play out if you have someone who has
really low self-esteem or social anxiety
or impostanedum for them they are
fighting you seeing who they worry they
truly are
like i am fighting with myself
constantly
that i i'm not an imposter that that i
want to prove my worth and i don't want
you to see that
i don't want you to see that i'm
fighting that all the time oh vanessa
but you are
i don't i don't think you're an imposter
like expound on that a little bit i
guess like where
where do you think
you think people people are uh what do
you think people think about where you
are versus like where you feel like you
are i think that the the hardest part
for me is i write about confidence and
charisma yeah we talked about this very
briefly earlier i wrote a book called
captivate i don't know what i was
thinking when i wrote that book i mean i
love that book it's a great book but
when you talk about being captivating
you have to be captivating all the time
right and so like but but you don't this
is you saying yeah i feel i do this is
the prison that you've you've placed
yourself in yeah now ryan and i
ironically
we
do certain things that people don't
perceive as minimalist right because we
own more than 15 items or
oh my god you were 16.
oh my god you wear underwear you drive a
car shame i'm just curious do you have
shame around that at all no i don't know
i used to have the imposter syndrome
right and maybe that that is kind of
maybe linked with shame a little bit but
anyway yeah keep keep going josh we
talked to we had a porn star on the
podcast her name is lisa ann where are
we going with this
anyway
this is a plug for our only fan's
account
yeah ryan asked her a brief question in
fact we're going to bring her back on
the podcast to talk do a whole episode
about shame he he asked do you ever deal
with shame you know being in the
industry that you're in she goes i find
that quite often people try to hand me
their shame yeah
the way that
they think i should feel ashamed for
what i'm doing right and i find that now
with minimalism i often like get other
people handing me their their shame
right now it could be a shame about my
situation their judgment on me of course
judgment is just a mirror of the
insecurities of the judge
or they're handing me their personal
shame like oh
i
feel ashamed and i can't embrace
simplifying my life because of the way
other people are going to think about me
i think there's this other path though
we were talking about this downstairs
off mike
i know that i'm awkward
and that knowing
that i'm awkward so what is the truth
behind this yeah yes i don't want to
come off as awkward maybe but i am
awkward so what am i saying i don't want
to come off as me i want to be
disingenuous as an enneagram three
that's easy for me to put that mask on
and say okay i'll put on a mask so i'm
not awkward be cool
but what about be myself what is
actually cooler than that being awkward
yeah right yeah so when you said that to
me earlier it like took my breath away
right because like i spent my life
trying to fight awkwardness and so for
you to say oh i am awkward so it's okay
if i am
was like
because i think that's that is extremely
authentic and so i think
when we talk about i was almost worried
to put out cues because it was i was
sharing with the world the operating
system i need to use to socially survive
and i was really scared about that
because i basically am admitting
i don't know how people work
i get really anxious on them i have to
memorize conversation starters and cues
to be able to interact and i was so
scared about that when i first put it
out there
but it's true yeah like when i'm
interacting i have to think
okay now do a head tilt now make eye
contact now use a gesture like that does
not come naturally to me i have to think
about it that way because i really want
to connect with people and so to connect
i have to have the right cues to do it
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free